y
[Música]
reino unido tendrá nuevo primer ministro
el 5 de septiembre los diputados de base
del partido conservador establecieron el
cronograma para reemplazar al saliente
boris johnson el comité de 1922
estableció nuevas reglas y la primera
ronda de votación empezará mañana
tenemos reporte desde londres
de mora en europa por la agudización de
la crisis energética rusia suspendió
temporalmente por 10 días el flujo de
gas natural por el gasoducto nord stream
por motivos de mantenimiento pero
alemania cree que el corte pueda ser
definitivo como represalia a las
tensiones por la guerra en ucrania
la primera ministra francesa elisabeth
born sobrevivió a su primera moción de
censura en la asamblea nacional la
medida promovida por la coalición de
partidos de izquierdas sólo obtuvo la
mitad de los votos necesarios para que
prosperara tenemos informe desde parís
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos a un reino unido
donde se conoció el cronograma para
elegir el reemplazo del primer ministro
boris johnson quien anunció su renuncia
la semana pasada el proceso comenzará
mañana mismo con las nominaciones y
terminará el 5 de septiembre cuando se
conozca el nombre del nuevo líder
británico vamos a ampliar la noticia
hasta londres con nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido luisa muy buenas tardes
cuéntenos cuál será el paso a paso para
elegir al nuevo primer ministro
buenas noches lo que ha anunciado
demuestra que los conservadores quieren
elegir al primer ministro del reemplazo
sobre johnson lo más rápido posible por
ello esta noche han modificado sus
reglas de este proceso de elección para
que sea de semanas y no de meses mañana
abrirán y cerrarán las candidaturas
entonces el miércoles empezará la
primera ronda de eliminación y luego el
jueves es importante que para esta etapa
en esta elección del 2022 los diputados
para que puedan tener una real opción de
candidatura necesitan el respaldo de al
menos 20 otros diputados se prevé que la
próxima semana muy posiblemente el lunes
queden dos candidatos dos finalistas
entonces ellos durante el verano en
agosto iniciarán una gira por todo el
país luego las bases del partido
conservador serán convocadas para que
puedan votar y el anuncio del nuevo
primer ministro como lo has resaltado
será el lunes 5 de septiembre y entonces
boris johnson tendrá que dejar astrid
iniciará una nueva etapa una nueva época
para este país luisa al día de hoy
quienes son los postulados a suceder a
bordillos
hay 11 candidatos hasta el momento pero
este martes cerrarán entonces las
candidaturas la posibilidad de
inscripciones entonces puede aumentar o
bajar lo cierto es que en esta lista de
11 candidatos hay hasta el momento 3
ministros de estado del actual gabinete
de boris johnson sobre ellos la ministra
de exteriores el ministro de transporte
y el recién designado ministro de
finanzas sorpresivamente esta noche se
han revelado encuestas que muestran que
los conservadores las bases y los
diputados tienen como favoritos a penny
mordente que fue la primera ministra de
defensa mujer del reino unido- también
el ex ministro de finanzas rich hizo una
que renunció el martes y generó todo
este terremoto político por el que boris
johnson tuvo que renunciar y
sorpresivamente también
tom dog hamm que es el secreto el
director de asuntos exteriores del
parlamento y sirvió como miembro de las
fuerzas militares en la guerra de
afganistán ellos lograrían ese apoyo de
20 diputados para pasar a la siguiente
etapa pero lo flexible de esta elección
conservadora es que puede haber muchas
sorpresas así que habrá que esperar
también están postulándose ésta javid
jeremy hunt suela braverman que me but
the work y richard city
de lo que sí estaremos al tanto de este
proceso luisa muchas gracias por ese
reporte desde londres cambiamos de tema
el gasoducto ruso nord stream 1
suspendió su suministro a alemania
debido a un mantenimiento programado por
10 días sin embargo occidente teme que
después de esta fecha la operación del
gasoducto más importante para europa no
continúe haciendo las entregas y rusia
hace un corte de suministro de manera
unilateral
occidente ha culpado a moscú de utilizar
el corte de suministro como un arma
política mientras que el kremlin se ha
defendido diciendo que algunos países no
han colaborado en el mantenimiento del
mismo el informe desde juan pabló lucumí
un escenario de incertidumbre para
europa el mantenimiento del gasoducto
más importante del viejo continente que
durará por lo menos 10 días ha puesto a
europa a buscar alternativas energéticas
ante un posible corte definitivo de las
entregas por parte de rusia occidente ha
señalado a moscú de usar el corte de gas
como respuesta a las sanciones que se le
han impuesto en castigo a su invasión a
ucrania el kremlin se ha desmarcado de
esas acusaciones
rechazamos totalmente cualquier
declaración de que la parte rusa está
utilizando el petróleo y el gas para
ejercer presión política hay ciertos
trabajos de mantenimiento en los
gasoductos estos trabajos se realizan
todos los años nadie ha inventado
ninguna reparación nueva
rusia ha señalado a canadá de ser el
principal culpable de que el gasoducto
pérez sólo a un 40 por ciento de su
capacidad luego de que el país
norteamericano no entregara unas
turbinas necesarias para el
mantenimiento del nord stream y mientras
ucrania se opone a que canadá colabore
en el mantenimiento del gasoducto moscú
ha puesto la entrega como condición
necesaria para aumentar el suministro a
europa
lo que ocurra una vez que se haya
realizado el mantenimiento está por
verse nadie puede predecirlo se trata de
un mantenimiento que termina en 10 días
o antes o después por desgracia tenemos
que esperar a ver qué pasa
afortunadamente alemania sigue
recibiendo gas de noruega a través de
las terminales de gas natural licuado en
bélgica y países bajos dimensión italia
es uno de los primeros damnificados del
cierre temporal en donde ya se habla de
un racionamiento de las empresas
energéticas y un control del consumo de
la calefacción y alumbrado público
alemania el país europeo que más depende
del gas ruso ya había empezado a tomar
medidas y según su ministro de economía
el abastecimiento de energía está
completamente garantizado
en francia la recién posesionada primera
ministra de elisabeth pons sobrevivió a
su primera moción de censura la medida
había sido promovida por la coalición de
partidos de izquierda nubes ante la
resistencia de born de someterse a una
moción de confianza al inicio de su
mandato la asamblea nacional solo obtuvo
146 de los 289 votos necesarios para su
adopción desde parís nuestra periodista
natalia ruiz con los detalles
la moción de censura contra el gobierno
de lisbeth bound no prosperó 146 votos a
favor nada más de los 289 que se
necesitaban para que fuera aprobada esta
moción fue presentada por las nubes la
coalición de izquierda y fue matilde
para no la jefe de los insumisos en la
asamblea nacional la que hizo la
presentación de este texto con palabras
muy duras contra elizabeth von otra la
primera ministra a quien tildó de
anomalía democrática diciendo que su
legitimidad pues se estaba en la era de
cuestionarse debido a los resultados de
las legislativas por un lado y por otro
el hecho de que ella no hubiera pedido
el voto de confianza de la asamblea
nacional la semana pasada cuando realizó
su discurso de política general luego a
esto bona dijo que esto más que todo era
una moción de postura y que se podría
utilizar el tiempo mejor sobre todo
tratando asuntos que le importan a los
franceses luego unieron cerca de dos
horas y media de debate sobre todo como
un ajuste de cuentas entre la izquierda
y la derecha todo esto sabiendo es que
tanto la reagrupación nacional la
extrema derecha como los conservadores
de los republicanos no votaron a favor
de esta moción de censura
dijeron además que no querían impedir el
actuar del gobierno pero que no por esto
significaba que tenía la confianza en
todo caso que no le estaban otorgando la
confianza ni a bona ni tampoco a emanuel
a maco el resultado de esta votación era
algo que ya se esperaba pero era la
oportunidad en todo caso para la 'nube
de demostrar que son la principal fuerza
de oposición
vamos a terreno ucraniano a 30 subió el
número de muertos tras un ataque con
cohetes rusos que golpeó un bloque de
apartamentos en la provincia de donges
que los servicios de emergencia trabajan
en el lugar para buscar sobrevivientes
pero hasta el momento sólo nueve
personas han sido rescatadas por otro
lado el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski dijo haber discutido con su
homólogo turco recep tayip erdogán sobre
la necesidad de desbloquear los puertos
de ucrania y reanudar sus exportaciones
de cereales los detalles desde el beef
con nuestra enviada especial catalina
gómez antes
el supuesto parón estratégico anunciado
por las fuerzas rusas días atrás no ha
sido sentido por la población de la
región del donbass donde está el
principal frente de batalla en este
momento en la provincia de don es que
una población conocida como chasing ya
hay al menos 30 personas fallecidas que
estuvieron bajo los escombros de una
edificación atacada este fin de semana
pero las fuerzas de rescate siguen
buscando más cadáveres en la ciudad de
jarc y también hubo otro ataque en un
momento en el que el presidente
ucraniano wladimir selenski habló por
teléfono con su contraparte turca el
presidente de recep tayyip erdogán para
hablar como poder desminar esos puertos
del mar negro poder abrir esas rutas
para sacar el grano que está en este
país no solamente el que se haya
acumulado en los silos y no ha podido
salir sino que se que se está empezando
a recoger unas cosechas que cada vez
presentan más preocupación no solamente
porque muchos de los campos están
minados sino que otros están siendo
quemados
y es que el freno en la exportación de
granos desde ucrania y genera cada vez
más preocupación sobre una crisis
alimentaria mundial europa ya advirtió
sobre una nueva oleada de emigrantes
como consecuencia de esta situación que
obligaría a las personas a abandonar sus
países de origen la comisaria de asuntos
interiores de la unión europea aseguró
que el continente debe prepararse e
instó a estar listos antes de que una
crisis migratoria se presente en sus
fronteras
personas se pueden encontrar en una
situación en la que no se sienten
seguros en sus países y entonces
comienzan a migrar por supuesto este es
un gran desafío y también algo de lo que
hemos discutido nadie puede predecir
cuántos serán
su visión northwave no debemos esperar
hasta que tengamos una crisis en
nuestras fronteras y hablando de
migración eeuu amplió por 18 meses más
el estatuto de protección temporal una
medida que ha permitido a miles de
venezolanos trabajar y residir
legalmente en el país de acuerdo con un
comunicado del departamento de seguridad
nacional el permiso que expiraba el 9 de
septiembre entrarán nuevas en vigencia
un día después y hasta el 10 de marzo de
2024 el llamado tps fue creado por el
congreso en 1990 para proteger a
migrantes y refugiados que podrían ver
en peligro su vida en sus países de
origen pero el gobierno biden lo aprobó
para venezuela en 2021
en argentina la nueva ministra de
economía anunció medidas de austeridad
para cumplir con el acuerdo con el fondo
monetariointernacional enfrentar la
crisis inflacionaria y solucionar el
descontento social andrés granadillo nos
cuenta más
austeridad para conjurar la crisis la
nueva ministra de economía argentina
silvana batakis anunció su plan para
controlar la espiral inflacionaria la
caída de los mercados y la creciente
presión sobre el peso además reiteró que
cumplirá con el acuerdo firmado en marzo
por el presidente alberto fernández para
refinanciar la deuda de 44 mil millones
de dólares con el fondo monetario
internacional que nosotros no vamos a
gastar más de lo que tenemos se
mantienen las metas acordadas con el
fondo monetario internacional si esto
también es muy importante nosotros ya
mantuvimos reuniones con las máximas
autoridades con kristalina georgieva y
también reuniones acá en argentina con
el representante del fondo monetario
para nuestro país y entendemos que es un
acuerdo que firmamos como estado y que
nosotros tenemos que cumplir el manejo
económico ha causado división el
oficialismo dividido entre el presidente
alberto fernández y la poderosa
vicepresidenta cristina fernández las
discusiones internas del gobierno se
centran en cómo enfrentar la inflación
del 65 por ciento anual una de las
mayores del mundo en la caída del poder
adquisitivo en las calles cientos de
opositores salieron para protestar
contra las medidas del gobierno
la designación de la nueva ministra
muestra que cambian de figurita pero no
cambia el rumbo económico que estoy
atado al de gm por esto creemos que es
necesario decir que lo que hace falta es
cambiar justamente ese rumbo
y pueden cambiar pero quieres vamos a
seguir pagando la crisis
el país sudamericano uno de los
principales exportadores de cereales
enfrenta una subida extrema del dólar
agravado por el aumento de precios de
las importaciones de energía que ha
ocasionado además que las reservas
internacionales del país disminuyan lo
que profundiza aún más la crisis de
argentina
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos pues los
invitamos a continuar con toda nuestra
programación nos vemos en minutos con
más noticias
[Música]